so yes thanks for that great
introduction I am Tara Hansen I work
with Robyn at the center and it's my
pleasure to act as your facilitator
today and I'd like to start off by just
making sure everybody's got their cell
phones off and then it's my pleasure to
introduce you to our speakers first
speaker today is Alexander Haslam he's a
senior CFR fellow he's a professor of
social and organizational psychology and
Australian laureate fellow at the
University of Queensland his work
examines how social identities and group
memberships influence our interactions
with others he researchers such
questions as how does belonging to
groups and organizations shape the way
we think feel and behave and how to or
individuals and groups in turn shape the
nature of organizations and society our
community responder will be Franco
savoia Franco is the non-governmental
co-chair of the aboriginal interagency
Council on homelessness and the director
of vibrant communities in Calgary he was
the president and CEO of the Edmonton
YMCA from 2002-2012 when he retired
after a 43 year career in the YMCA that
began in nineteen sixty-nine at the
Greater Toronto YMCA where he worked in
various positions including vice
president in 1989 he became the CEO at
st. Catherine's and Niagara Falls YMCA
and over the next 11 years he led a
volunteer and staff team to build a
brand new YMCA for that community that
would serve nearly 12,000 members Franco
has a Bachelor of Arts from the
University of Windsor and a master of
theology from the University of Toronto
in 2002 he completed a master of
management from McGill University in the
McGill McConnell program for voluntary
sector leaders he played a leadership
role in the development of the
ymc welcome village that opened in 2012
in Edmonton and has been a Rotarian for
22 years so take it away Alexander and
Franco thank you very much for that
excellent sort of tripartite
introduction that was great I've my name
is alex i'm here from Australia just I'm
going to be talking a lot about groups
and kind of why and how they're good for
you today so I'll just say a little bit
about some of the groups that I belong
to I was my family in the UK and in
Australia I belonged to a very large
kind of network of researchers and much
of the work that I'm going to pass off
as my own today is actually theirs is
part of a collaborative Enterprise in
particular with colleagues at the
University of Queensland obviously too i
want to acknowledge our membership
catherine my own rods membership of CFR
which has been a fantastic sponsor of
our work now for 10 years cath and I are
not I'm Canadian you'll probably work
that out for our accents but I think we
feel like we're parts of a virtual
comate Canadian community and that's
that's a wonderful thing and I think I'm
importantly to I think see far has
reinforced our sense of ourselves as
citizens of the world which is also very
important and one final thing I mustn't
forget for those on the podcast and
those are few people in Australia our
people our neighbors I want to say hello
to Maureen and Carly and holcomb flower
it's one thirty in the morning so if
your app top marks okay and on we go so
I'm going to talk again about I'm going
to talk about social identity and groups
but I want to start by explaining why
that is so central to psychology and to
the themes and issues that we're going
to talk about today if you start with a
question what does it mean to be human a
fairly obvious starting point is that
humans are social animals and what that
means in very basic terms is that we
live and have evolved to live in a range
of social groups ethnic groups political
groups national groups religious group
family groups
groups sporting groups interest groups
and so on and as a result of that a
large part of our sense of self who we
think we are is derived from membership
of those social groups those groups in
sort of technical language furnish us
with a sense of social identity and in
another context another time another
place I've presented a see far talk
which argues effectively that who we are
as individuals is very much a product
and a reflection of the groups that we
belong to they provide us with bearings
Direction purpose norms and a whole
range of other things so if I really
want to understand who you are each of
you as individuals I could ask you to
list your personality traits and you
could say I'm happy or I'm honest or all
these kinds of things trustworthy but if
I really wanted to know you like I know
well you're a woman and you belong your
feminist you belong to this neighborhood
watch group or whatever it might be and
you enjoy hockey assuming everybody in
Alberta does okay so um I I learned this
from the radio interview yesterday in
which everything was about hockey I
didn't realize that until yesterday but
now I do okay so um again if we kind of
look at what that might look like what
we're saying is that our sense of self
is derived from a membership and social
groups that is reflecting in everyday
language in our use of terms we and us
often psychologists treats those terms
as if they're epiphenomenon if they're
not really real they don't really relate
to the self and that the true self is
about I and me and our research and the
research of collaborators and colleagues
really around the world suggest that
that's not the case that in many ways
our true self is grounded in those group
memberships and that that sense of self
when I think about myself as US
Australians or us men or us supporters
of newcastle united or whatever it might
be then that defines me as a member of a
community and it furnishes we with a
very particular sense of self that's
irreducible to the sense of
self that is associated with my
individuality but interestingly to our
research shows that our sense of strong
individuality strong personality strong
personal identity derives from those
group memberships so just as an example
if as an individual on my own actually
it's quite hard to get one's bearings in
the social world to have a sense of
place but for example the fact i'm here
now as a representative of seafaring
academic community actually gives me a
place gives me a purpose and makes me
feel stronger in myself in a sense it
gives me the strength to present to you
it gives me a sense of what I'm meant to
be doing allows me to overcome all
manner of obstacles not the lisa which
is 16 hours of jet lag ok so again we're
as often psychology privileges the
personal self as if psychology is all
about me and I our work is about
inverting that and saying that really
psychology is much more about we and us
and that's fundamental to the way in
which that psychology has evolved
another way of thinking about what
social identity kind of does is that
social identity turns other into self so
is it as a simple example until a couple
of weeks ago Franco was just another
person on the planet he had meant
nothing to me at all and I meant nothing
to him ok he was just an other but now
that we're bonded together as part of
this community this intellectual
dialogue that we actually have a sense
of each other's having some common
purpose so Franco is no longer a
stranger he is part of who I am and he
has the ability he's a reference for me
and i can get my sense of self partly
from him and similarly I'm attentive to
what he says in a way that would not
have been true two weeks ago more
fundamentally a large body of research
shows that that sense of social identity
a sense of your connection to other
people is the basis for a whole range of
forms of group behavior there in a sense
and this is a kind of famous line from
the kind of social identity
social identity is what makes group
behavior possible and as a result it's a
UC and there's again various lines of
research that we've been doing over the
last dozen or so years which show that
social identity is a basis for
communication why am I talking to you
and why are you listening to me because
we share social identity if we were out
on the street and we're strangers we
would have no reason to interact with
each other we trust each other I saw
someone just leaving their handbag we
nearly around why well because you feel
that you're part of this community use
you trust the person next to you to
behave in a civil manner towards you
don't you can kind of internalize that
and take that for granted you feel
connection to people used to have a
sense of solidarity so you have
collective emotions around the pot that
the circumstances of the group that
you're in either positive or negative
there's a basis for influence for
organization more generally against
social identity and this is our
organization work makes processes like
organization and leadership possible you
can't lead unless you can invoke a sense
of social identity that connects you to
potential followers and that too is also
a basis for power that actually power
comes through our ability to mobilize
people in the name and the vision of a
shared collective sense of what we're
about so we get power through other
people rather than power being a process
of having power over people actually
true power is an influence process again
grounded in social identity ok now what
that's a lot of those things are things
that I could talk about on another day
and perhaps you'll invite us back to do
that but for today I'm going to really
I've actually a bit of a curtain raiser
for cath who's going to talk a lot more
about mental health and she's a
clinician in a way that I'm not so I'm
also a bit of a fraud I have to fess up
to that too but i want to say those
things feed into mental health because
again social identity through those
various processes are basis for things
like and again this is part of our
ongoing research self-esteem control the
sense of belonging the provision and the
receipt of social support a sense of
coping a sense of resilience a sense of
purpose and a sense of meaning and again
each of those things
we have colleagues who have kind of
demonstrated each of those links pretty
conclusively if you want to put those
things together in terms of a model
which kind of again one of the things
that psychologists like to do is to
compartmentalize the world and pretend
the social psychology over here and
clinical psychology over here and
organizational psychology there and
developmental psychology over there
actually all work speaks to a unity of
those processes bounded in this sense of
identity and what you see is that social
identity is a basis for connection
organization community which then is a
basis for support and coping resilience
that needs into control purpose and
meaning which in turn buttresses mental
health and then allows people to grow as
part of a community and part of a group
that's what we refer to as the Vischer
the virtuous circle of social
identification and that's kind of if you
like a kind of a very positive rosy
picture of what of the affordances if
you like of social identity however
unfortunately we live in a world where
it's not always possible for everybody
to live out positive social identities
for a range of people and probably for
all of us at certain points in our lives
valued and valuable social identities
will come under threat and in particular
those threats are manifest in the form
of various life transitions aging we've
done a lot of research on people
entering care homes unemployment's again
losing links to your professional and
work-related identities we should define
who you are for a long period of time
obviously discrimination directly if you
like attacks the value of the identities
that you hold dear whether they're
gender-based or ethnically based and so
on and finally think proce larger scale
processes like colonization or war again
threaten those identities and so the
extent that those kinds of transitions
again undermine a sense of social
identity then we argue and indeed
there's really bucket loads of evidence
that speaks at this point that they
completely constitute a major risk
for mental health so if you like the odd
verse of the virtuous circle of social
identification is a vicious circle of
social atomization in which a lack or
loss of social identity is a basis for
disconnection and isolation a sense of
alienation and a lack of support
frustration enemy listlessness in
certain sense and then distress
despression depression and dysfunction
and then that reduced sense of your
place in the world at large now those
ideas I've said a really being and
really since the foundation of this see
file program which has been a major
driver for this research initiative in
the course of this program which is now
12 years old that these issues have
become kind of a focus for burgeoning
interest these are just the number of
papers on social identity and health for
the last sort of 25 years and again you
can sort of see that in recent years
they've really sort of taken off and I
should say to that those are I think map
onto other developments in the social
sciences so if you go into the bookshop
in town you'll see a range of books
which speak about the importance of the
social about the importance of community
and I think there's a broader recognized
mission around the world about the
importance of the things that we're
going to be talking about today that
work speaks to the fact that social
identities central to mental health in
part because social identity is is part
of if you like the benefits of things
like the environment our sense of space
or connection to the world in which we
live things like religion again a lot of
the positive powers of religion comes
through social identity range of mass
gatherings some of our research
colleagues have done a lot of research
in India looking at congregations of
millions of people and the ability of
those two again foster a sense of
collective well-being cast on a lot of
work on the role of social identity in
protecting mental health and cognitive
health because actually social identity
is a basis for you to engage with other
people and to stretch
yourself intellectually which again if
you like underpins cognitive performance
particularly in aging and it's also at
the heart of successful clinical
interventions and as I've already
intimated the leadership that makes
those interventions are possible and
again I hope in the discussion later we
will have a little space to think about
the ways in which leadership is a
critical part of the processes that I'm
going to talk about quickly okay so
there's a little bit of theory and
perhaps more than you would have liked
but I think it's very important to
contextualize this in a much larger
literature much larger body of research
which is sometimes overlooked let's just
talk about some kind of specifics which
kind of if you like put some flesh on
that theoretical bone this is a study we
published last year we are using data
from the English longitudinal survey on
Aging it's a sample of over 4,000 people
about a ten percent of whom are
depressed reflecting this is over long
period of time reflecting kind of
general population levels of depression
but it's an aging population so these
are people are over 50 and one of the
things that we were looking at there's
lots of things you can use that data to
tell you about these processes but one
that's kind of indicative of the general
patterns that emerge from that is to
look at the if you like the trajectory
of people who are have a history of
depression and what are the things that
if you like ameliorate depression and if
you like reduce the risk of relapse this
is the percentage of people who relapse
two years after one wave of the study as
a function of the number of groups that
they have joined in the intervening
period well if at time one you don't you
you but you don't between time 1 and
time to you don't join any new groups
then the chance of depression relapse is
about forty percent again what we had no
in the population at large so the risk
of relapse is very high but the credit
the most if you like I think effect
same thing that a person can do to
buffer themselves from the risk of
relapse is to join new social groups so
you see there that if you belong to
three or more groups then effectively
your risk of relapse was more than
halved okay um some other kind of
evidence this is a this is something
again at that so that's a study of again
elderly people a specific population
just a completely different type of
context again to give some indicative
evidence this is just a should say to
this is a metra nurses are all the
studies which are the relationship
between social identity and depression
what you see is a pretty robust
relationship across those studies as I
said there's about 15 of them and in all
of them you see that negative
relationship so that social
identification is associated with lower
levels of depression moving as set into
a different type of context so that's
you might say will depress people and
people have depression on clinical kind
of issues that's not me this is a study
of just a meta-analysis that I should
say that previous work was done by a
colleague to tegan Kruis at UQ this is
work done by another of our colleagues
Nick Stefan's this is a meta-analysis of
the relationship between social
identification and stress in the
workplace okay this is 50 studies that
look at social identification extent to
which people identify either with their
work team or with the organization that
employs them and their levels of stress
okay more generally and again this is
covering cumbersome things like burnout
and phasing into anxiety and also a
depression what you see in what that
data shows is that across a very large
number of studies large number of
participants there's a very reliable
relationship so that high levels of
social identification are associated
with low levels of stress that's a very
robust finding is no it's a kind of
resistant to all manner of statistical
tests too if you like eliminate it and
so that's your work group identification
and similarly organizational
identification so feeling that you are
part of a wee us in this work team or us
in this organization is absolutely
critical to mental health in the
workplace which of course is has massive
kind of economic and other kinds of
costs okay if it's not addressed
successfully and yes what's interesting
again I sort of challenged you is that
is that when people talk about stress
they almost always make it a kind of
personal issue they very rarely talk
about it in terms of these group based
kind of processes and yet our research
suggests that group dynamics and the
process of social identification are
critical to that phenomena and again
I've used those if you like those
examples took as bookends to a compass
the whole spectrum of mental health kind
of issues from depression through two
more everyday things like stress ok so
again those that data though is
population-based data and it's
correlational so a question that I think
you probably want answered is ok well
can you show me kind of what one might
do about this and also can you establish
this court a causal relationship between
social identification stress this is
another study that a Tegan and and we
conducted at in Brisbane it was some
research that was done with a population
of vulnerable participants some of whom
were homeless others were having other
kind of life challenges that they were
struggling to overcome they had made
contact with an organization called rec
link Australia is a charitable
organization and effectively what
wreckling does is to get people who are
as I say disadvantaged or vulnerable and
identify groups that they might join on
the basis of their if you like the
biographical and historical kind of
details and careful pick up this thread
a little bit later on ok so try to find
out what potential social
identifications people might have and
then put them in groups and look at what
the effects of that is well obviously
with a view to helping them overcome to
various challenges that they face they
approached us because
as is the way in Australia at least
they're funding was being cut and they
wanted some evidence that actually what
they were doing was worthwhile they knew
it was but they didn't have the data so
that the pharmaceutical companies have
if you'd like to justify the kinds of
things that they wanted to do so again
we conducted this study over a long
period of time and again its ongoing
this research what we did looked at
people Predis intervention look at their
mental health and post-intervention and
what you see is that on average
participation in this program reduces
depression actually very considerably
takes people from kind of well on
average well above the threshold for
depression diagnosis to an average below
that threshold but interestingly to that
that that effect is moderated by the
extent to which people identify with the
groups in question so just if I just
took anyone here who maybe have some
issues or problems and just put you in
any old group a one that you don't
identify with it's probably not going to
have much benefit for your mental health
but if I put you in a group that if you
like really furnishes you with this
sense of we and us so you feel
connection to the people in it then
actually what you see is a massive
improvement in mental health over the
course of that intervention ok and again
Kath is going to pick that theme up in a
minute so again just to abstract some
kind of things during to which this of
which this indicative work is indeed
speaks to some of the points are ongoing
work I think brings robust and rich
theory to a range of phenomena that are
central to mental health but we would
argue a poorly understood within from
from a kind of mainstream
individualistic psychological
perspective again in large part because
that marginalizes if you like the social
determinants of mental health it points
to the way in which a neglect of social
identity dynamics leads to sub optimal
outcomes I put this picture in again
because often when you see Munch's the
scream you focus on the kind of
individuals suffer in the center and you
don't necessarily think about the
broader social context what are those
people doing there how do they relate to
that person what's their role in
supporting them or whatever they running
away from them or
and actually the point of munchies
painting or as he describes it was
indeed too if you like speak to some of
those dynamics but again when that
picture is kind of reproduce that's
often not what we see also i think this
research shows how the power of groups
and social identity which is as I say
routinely overlooked can and needs to be
harnessed to deliver significant health
benefits and the point I'd make is that
individual sufferers need to be
understood and treated or managed in the
context of their social identities more
broadly and this is a kind of
theoretical analysis that we've done if
you kind of abstract from this
literature kind of five key practical
points about if you like turning theory
into practice there I think five points
that I would want to make the first is
that groups and social identities are
critical to mental health hopefully I've
made that point reasonably convincingly
but again if I haven't or you need more
proof more evidence I've got a bucket
load out the back so to speak and I'm
happy to share that with you also
importantly it's groups matter but so
does self categorizations we have to
internalize those groups as part of who
we are so that groups become
self-defining so you know us Canadians
that's a self categorization I see
myself as a member of that social
identity that social category also when
it comes to kind of practitioner
interventions the power of social
identities is unlocked by working with
those group memberships not across or
against them off a lot of my other work
is on organizational change and often
when leaders or when you get a new
leader in they do a bit of
organizational change they pay very
little attention to the group based
dynamics on the ground they treat people
as if they're blobs on a wiring diagram
and you can cut them up this way and
that way and repackage them and it will
work smoothly eighty percent of
organizational restructurings fail why
because they pay no attention to social
identity dynamics if you if you do if
you if you tackle these kinds of issues
in a way that's negligent of the power
of social identities you will always get
it wrong
you know that's just a fundamental point
for anyone is thinking about leadership
or all those kinds of things you've got
to think first about what is the nature
of the groups that I'm trying to work
with and if you are insensitive to those
things your leadership will fail that so
I can make you that prediction you know
dead it's a fact okay so another level
it's not again a lot of this is not just
about social if you like talking about
or acknowledging social identities it's
also about working with them to make
them matter to turn the idea of us into
a practical reality so that people can
live out valued identities actually
that's something again isn't important
if you like secret to leadership again
if you think about our membership of
this community it's the fact that we can
come together and do something practical
and collaborative and that makes us
matter and then is a vehicle for things
to kind of move forward so it's not just
about thinking about us it's about
making us matter and making us if you
like a potent force in the world and so
the extent that you do that you empower
people through social identity then
again you don't just have positive
benefits on mental health you're
actually able to engage in progressive
forms of social change and finally a
point of course every you know 99
percent of change and health management
is going on the world is happening you
know pretty much oblivious to the things
that I'm saying here today what I would
say though is whatever you do in this
space even if you completely neglects
all the things i'm talking about it what
you're doing is that some level always
having an impact on social identities so
again if i do some restructuring and i
decide to split up a work team or i
decide to cut it this way rather than
that way i'm always if you like
tinkering with adjusting social
identities and what I do will always
have consequences through those
identities I might not acknowledge that
I might recognize that my denying the
whole range of other things but that's
always the case and I would also argue
that that is at the very heart of if you
like the political process the politics
of organizational life
the politics of society that as as
leaders as community members as
politicians we make decisions about
which identities to prioritize which
identities to privilege and to listen to
and which ones we're not going to attend
to a which ones we're going to d
legitimate in various ways and so if you
like I want to argue that if you like
not just that identity is about
psychology identity is about politics
indeed it's at the heart of politics and
I don't want to if you like deny the
political dimensions of what we're
talking about because I think you have
to acknowledge this isn't just about the
science it's also about people's
willingness to acknowledge particular
group based agendas and to run with them
and again and what you see in whether
you're talking about Britain or Canada
and Australia is there is some
resistance if you like to acknowledging
and engaging with some identities as
distinct from others and this is the
final slide you'll be pleased to know
and this again this is a bit of a
curtain raiser for what cats going to
say social identity then I think and
more broadly our aspiration is that it
provides the basis for a potent
partnership between social psychologists
or psychologists more generally and
practitioners and even though as I
pointed before there's really a lot of
work that's really Stein's come out I
think that actually we've only really
started to scratch the surface of that
in part because it's only in the last
couple of years that we have gone out to
communities of practitioners communities
of policymakers like yourselves people
are actually at the coalface at the
cutting edge dealing with these problems
it's only recently that we started to
have a dialogue about well what might
this look like in this space I think
that's tremendously kind of exciting
work it's obviously the next phase of
our research and i believe it is indeed
genuinely a transformational
tremendously exciting and i know we're
kind of very excited very tired because
we spend a lot of time in aeroplanes but
um but it's really it's great to have
these conversations around us and I
think that really we're very much you
know day one of this in a sort of
broader scheme of things so this is very
much the beginning and again we're still
very much at the point where we're very
keen to take on board the perspectives
and problems and issues
that practitioners and the translators
of these ideas are grappling with what I
think what we're doing in many ways is
reintroducing the psychology of the self
into clinical theorizing if you go back
into the history of clinical psychology
early on Freud and others were talking
very much about the self but actually
that research got bogged down and it
didn't get very far altima tlie so
people moved away from the idea that
mental health was about the self and our
argument is that that is because that
literature always again was locked into
this idea of the self is something that
was based in the individual and their
individuality rather than the self is
something that's fundamentally social
and grounded in a collective identity I
think once you if you like make that
step change then it opens up a whole if
you like vista of intellectual and
practical possibilities again this
promotes an analysis in which the we of
self is central and points to the value
of clinical interventions again which
were that value which are only starting
to if you like clarify and a document
that have that same group based focus
and finally the last thing because I
think such interventions develop the
skills that allow people to connect or
reconnect with meaningful social groups
we expect them to promote resilience and
to have enduring benefits and I say that
really is a contrast from say sure we
say pharmaceutical intervention I think
I think I think drugs absolutely have a
place again but part of the problem with
drugs is that they induce a certain form
of dependence and that when you come off
them typically the problems that if you
like that they were covering up or
masking resurface I think we would argue
that when you tackle issues of social
identity you get to the core of many not
all many mental health issues and by
addressing those then you can build if
you like a enduring long-term solution
to those problems which is not only have
been
fit to the individual suffer but also to
the groups and communities around them
that's again we've starting to get data
which I think speaks very much that
point but again we need to do the kind
of longitudinal kind of research that
substantiates those kinds of points I
hold that out as a prediction as a
hypothesis as a promise but that is
clearly a check that needs to be cached
and I want to make the point that it is
not possible to cash those intellectual
checks without the support of very many
funding agencies of in Australia and in
the UK in the past but in particular we
appreciate the massive support that
we've received from CFR and from the
Canadian community more generally and I
should say to that that support is not
just material and financial it is also
if you like spiritual in the sense that
we've always felt that Canada has if you
like as a particularly warm home for our
ideas people have always been responded
very positively to them and they've
always if you like being great partners
in the process of developing that and
long may it be so thank
Thank You Alexander I have a question
for us why are we here this morning why
did you come you could have been doing
lots of other things why did you come
and those all the folks on webcast you
know why we're here because we're
addicts what are you talking about I
like my few comments be informed by
Gadsby's book closing the mental gap
closing the mind gap it's quite powerful
I've reread it a couple of times most
recently is that we hunger for answers
we hunger for answers like we according
to evolutionary biologists and in terms
of Gatsby's kind of run on the things is
we need answers and you know what thank
God we were wired that way cuz we've
survived about 500 million years
apparently and certainly the last 12,000
it's got us this far because it's been
relatively simple issues as farmers and
agricultural we now have come to a new
point in a very very complex complex
situation the complex of poverty
reduction of ending homelessness of the
whole issues of mental health these are
not simple situations at all but we want
simple solutions we're wired to do that
what Alexander is kind of suggesting is
folks relax we gotta look at things way
way differently way differently is that
you know even the notion of self there's
lots been written on that and the
research that he's commented on his
phenomenal but it throws you for a loop
that's not the way I thought of myself
as a self Franco exists he's here mikasa
well the fact is without all my
relationships there is no Franco really
we know that but that's not we don't
like that answer okay because it's not
instinctive you know that isn't the way
it is so I think the notion very much is
is I reflect on the presentation is that
we really do have to stay take a step
back very very much we are living in a
very very complex world all of us in
leadership positions in this room and
the wisdom and the people listening in
we got to be very very careful about how
quickly we assume solutions and wanting
those simple solutions they don't exist
in fact if we who ever is here 100 years
from now and reflects on this day
they'll say you know what they were
thinking back I'm februari the fifth in
Edmonton can you believe that I often
think about that so we think that we've
got it all figured out we're going to
figure it out it's not going to happen
folks but we're going to work really
really hard to get there so here in
Alberta we all know many of us in this
room all the seven cities we have ten
year plans the end to end homelessness
we said there won't be a homeless person
in 2019 in Alberta we have housed 8,000
people we have now realized what
Alexander is mentioning to that in fact
you got to work within the individual in
connections just putting them in an
apartment will not work so now we're
building some supports to kind of
establish that but i think it's deeper
than that because we don't see those
folks as human beings like us where the
helpers and they're the helped a real
problem a real problem and what i would
argue in terms of what the kind of
things Alexander said is paradoxically
the thing that's got us to the state
dark tribalism is the very thing that in
fact could do us in because we got to
move ourselves to a deeper level at what
point what's more important am i a human
being or am i a canadian or i'm a member
of the ymca
or whatever that gives me part of my
identity how do we get down into the
future that really talks about and
there's lots of other writers are saying
is if we don't get there and work the
liberty of that establishing our common
humanity we're doomed as a species this
is dramatic and this is enough now and
we now know that this is wired into us
so this is why the question becomes in
what are we going to do in this research
that Alexander is put before us and
they'll be much much more research it's
going to continue to evolve so like any
kind of piece of good work that he's
presented us it leaves many more
questions and almost no answers but
that's the way it should be I'm excited
by that now when I was 20 years old I
had all the answers so I didn't have to
bother I really didn't I really had all
the answers as I get older I realized
that fewer and fewer answers and more
and more and more questions but I'm
excited about that I'm excited because
there's a future in that the future
there is no future when you figure
you've got the answers and so I think
that's the challenge see far I'm so
delighted with with what's what's
happening here so I think very much I
think at the end of the day the notion
for all of us in this room and then on
the webcast is what is our own position
on this will we be mindful for a little
bit just a little when we're sitting
around the leadership tables and the
kind of stuff and saying and ask more
questions many more questions don't get
hung up with one answer because in
complexity there is no one solution it
does not exist if you soon as you do
that you have doomed the failure so
we're now saying in poverty reduction in
Calgary because we're we got our whole
strategy and implementing this whole
kind of collaborative and it's going to
be very tough we got to bring all the
sectors together people that don't never
talk to each other to say how we're
going to come at this because we're all
involved let me show you just how
endemic this is with some folks in the
lib voice we brought working working
poor people that are starting out of
homelessness
and I was facility in a small group not
like this most in 25-35 he said you know
we're going in and out of shelters we've
been indeed they have issues that's the
mental health issues and they said you
know not one person has ever asked me
what I'd like to do no one person is
ever asked what I'm good at and one
pretty another young guy says I love to
draw so we have to be extremely more
mindful because our natural tendency is
to give the answer give a solution I'm
going to fix you Franco no you're not no
you're not we got to come back and
accept truly are really our common
humanity so in some ways paradoxically
in a son in a sense what the research is
saying is also could do us in its
paradoxical because we've got to get
beyond that how do we do that how do we
do that when our identity is tied into
our groups we've got to somehow move it
further down I don't know how that is
made more research and you get a
thousand years maybe five hundred years
from now because this 1300 cc thing here
that we all have I wish sometimes we had
no hair which just was just a clear bulb
we could see all the just that all the
stuff that's going on in our brains
continuously 24-7 because it's going on
all the time that's a fact and the
question be is holly is only by becoming
mindful taking a moment or two or
reflecting together and asking the real
questions in Alberta we have a huge
issue with with Aboriginal I mean the
aboriginal challenges in Canada in fact
okay the question would be is I was in a
session a couple of weeks ago and one of
the leaders said would you please stop
doing it to us we're not at fam machine
to be fixed I mean that's that's how
they feel the racism and so on like that
when will we accept that because partly
it's better than their the aboriginals
and this is part of the identity where
the non-aboriginal we happen to be the
dominance and the legislative and that
kind of stuff
this isn't this is so central to our
life here in Canada these are real
issues so I think I've the interest is
to more speakers and actually for more
speakers so let me kind of end the
notion here is questions let me in
because I came across this Margaret
wheatley's I just loved some of her
stuff Jay and but she said this has kind
of a way to position our work from today
onwards and she said there is no greater
power there's no sorry there's no power
greater than a community discovering
what it cares about you can see a
community is more than just a group
right ask what's possible not what's
wrong keep asking notice what you care
about assume that many others share your
dreams be brave enough to start a
conversation that matters talk to people
you know talk to people you don't know
talk to people you never talk to be
intrigued by the differences you hear
expect to be surprised treasure
curiosity more than certainty inviting
everybody who cares to work on what's
possible acknowledge that everyone is an
expert about something know that
creative solutions come from new
connections remember you don't fear
people whose story you know read real
listening always brings people closer
together trust that meaningful
conversations change your world rely on
human goodness stay together thank you
you